Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do at the SCP Foundation: If a mind-controlling
SCP is discovered, it is to be turned over
to the proper authorities.
It is not to be used to advance himself or
others higher in the Foundation.
Look, we’ve all wanted to be more persuasive
people.
Maybe it’s about getting a new job, or a
raise, or convincing your buddies to see the
movie you want to see at the theater, rather
than the Steven Segal movies they always insist
on.
But Dr. Bright using mind-controlling SCPs
to help advance himself at the Foundation,
or making Dr. Kondraki pee his pants so that
he can take his projects while Kondraki is
put on mandatory mental health leave, is simply
not acceptable professional conduct.
Isn’t Dr. Bright anomalously powerful enough
already?
We really don’t need him gaining the power
to control the human mind.
It just won’t end well.